algunos de ellas de 1,5 x 2,5 m
como esta.
Para esta pintura, he mezclado con harina el agua del baño para hacerla turbia
y vertí aceite de cocina en la superficie
y puse una chica en ella,
y cuando lo ilumine,
era tan hermoso que no podía esperar a pintarlo.
Estaba motivada por este tipo de curiosidad impulsiva,
siempre buscando algo nuevo que añadir:
vinilo, vapor, vidrio.
Una vez puse toda esta vaselina en mi cabeza y pelo
para ver cómo se vería así.
No hagan eso.
(Risas)
Así que me iba bien.
Estaba encontrando mi camino.
Era ambiciosa y estaba motivada
y rodeada de artistas,
siempre en inauguraciones y eventos.
Tenía un poco de éxito y reconocimiento
y me mudé a un apartamento con más de cuatro enchufes.
Mi madre y yo trasnochábamos
hablando de nuestras últimas ideas inspirándonos la una a la otra.
Hacía hermosa cerámica.
Tengo un amigo que se llama Bo que hizo esta pintura
de su esposa y yo bailando por el océano,
y la llamó "La Años Luz".
Le pregunté qué significaba eso y me dijo:
"Es cuando uno ha entrado en la edad adulta, ya no eres un niño,
pero uno todavía no está lastrado por las responsabilidades de la vida".
Eso fue todo. Fueron años de luz.
El 8 de octubre de 2011,
los años de luz llegaron a su fin.
Mi madre fue diagnosticada con cáncer de pulmón.
Se había extendido a sus huesos y estaba ya en su cerebro.
Cuando me dijo esto, caí de rodillas.
Totalmente perdida.
Y cuando llegué a dominarme y a mirarla,
me di cuenta, no se trata de mí.
Era de cómo encontrar la manera de ayudarla.
Mi padre es médico
así que teníamos una gran ventaja de tenerlo a cargo,
y él hizo un gran trabajo cuidando de ella.
Pero yo también quería hacer todo lo posible para ayudar,
así que quería probar todo.
Todos lo hicimos.
Investigué medicinas alternativas,
dietas, jugo, acupuntura.
Por último, le pregunté,
"¿Es esto lo que quieres que haga?".
Y ella dijo: "No".
Dijo: "Cálmate. Voy a necesitarte más adelante".
Ella sabía lo que estaba ocurriendo,
y sabía lo que los médicos
y los expertos y el Internet no sabían:
la forma en que quería pasar por esto.
Solo tuve que preguntárselo.
Me di cuenta de que si trataba de arreglarlo,
me lo perdería.
Así que empecé a estar con ella,
en cualquiera situación y en cualquiera de ellas
realmente solo la escuchaba.
Si antes yo estaba resistiendo, ahora yo estaba rindiéndome,
renunciando a tratar de controlar lo incontrolable
y simplemente yo estaba allí en eso con ella.
El tiempo se ralentizó
y la fecha era irrelevante.
Habíamos desarrollado una rutina.
Cada mañana me gustaba meterse en la cama con ella y dormir con ella.
Mi hermano venía para el desayuno
y nos poníamos muy contentas de oír el auto llegando por el camino.
Y la ayudaba a levantarse, tomando sus manos
y la ayudada a caminar a la cocina.
Tenía una enorme taza que hizo
le gustaba beber su café de ella.
Y le encantaba el pan de soda irlandés para el desayuno.
Posteriormente la ducha,
y le encantaba esta parte.
Le encantaba el agua tibia,
así que hice eso tan indulgente como podía,
como un spa.
Mi hermana ayudaba a veces.
Teníamos toallas calientes
y zapatillas preparadas de inmediato,
así que nunca se enfrió ni un segundo.
La secaba con el secador el pelo.
Mis hermanos venían por las tardes y llevaban a sus hijos,
y ese era el punto culminante de su día.
Con el tiempo, empezamos a utilizar una silla de ruedas,
y no quería comer tanto,
y utilizaba la taza de té más pequeña que pudimos encontrar para beber su café.
Ya no podía hacerlo yo todo sola
así que contratamos una ayudante, para que me ayudara con las duchas.
Estas actividades diarias simples
se convirtieron en nuestro ritual sagrado,
y las repetimos día tras día
mientras crecía el cáncer.
Fue humillante y doloroso
y era exactamente donde yo quería estar.
Llamamos a este tiempo "lo horrible bello".
Murió el 26 de octubre de 2012.
Fue un año y tres semanas tras su diagnóstico.
Se fue.
Mis hermanos, hermana, padre y yo
todos nos unimos en esta manera solidaria y de atenciones.
Era como si toda nuestra dinámica familiar
y todos nuestros roles establecidos se desvanecieran
y estábamos todos juntos en ese desconocido,
sintiendo la misma cosa
y cuidando el uno del otro.
Y estoy muy agradecida con ellos.
Como alguien que pasa la mayor parte del tiempo sola trabajando en mi estudio,
no tenía ni idea de que este tipo de conexión
podría ser tan importante para la curación.
Esto fue lo más importante.
Era lo que siempre quise.
Así que tras el funeral, ya era hora de volver a mi estudio.
Así que empaqué todo en mi auto y volví a Brooklyn,
y pinté que es lo que siempre he hecho, y eso es lo que hice.
Y esto es lo que pasó.
Es como una liberación de todo lo que se estaba desmoronándose en mí.
Ese lugar seguro, muy, muy cuidadosamente creado
que creé en todas mis otras pinturas,
era un mito.
No funcionó.
Y tuve miedo, porque no quería pintar más.
Así que entré en el bosque.
Pensé, voy a intentar salir.
Tengo mis pinturas y no era una pintora paisajista,
pero tampoco era, en absoluto, un tipo de pintora realmente.
así que no tenía apego, sin expectativas,
lo que permitió que fuera imprudente y libre.
En realidad, fui una de estas pinturas húmedas
toda la noche fuera
al lado de una luz en el bosque.
Por la mañana estaba plagado de insectos.
Pero no me importaba. No importaba. No importaba.
Llevé todas estas pinturas de nuevo a mi estudio,
las raspé y tallé en ellas,
y vertí disolvente de pintura en ellas,
puse más pintura en la parte superior, dibujé en ellas.
No tenía ningún plan,
pero veía lo que estaba ocurriendo.
Esta es la que tiene todos los insectos.
No trataba de representar un espacio real.
Era el caos y las imperfecciones que me resultaban fascinantes,
y algo empezó a suceder.
Me picó la curiosidad de nuevo.
Esta es otra de las maderas.
Ahora, sin embargo, había una salvedad.
No podía controlar la pintura como solía hacerlo.
Tenía que ser algo de implicación e insinuación,
sin explicación ni descripción.
Y que la superficie imperfecta, caótica y turbulenta
es la historia que se contaba.
Empecé a ser tan curiosa como cuando era estudiante.
Así que lo próximo que quería era poner figuras en estas pinturas, gente,
y me encantó este nuevo entorno,
así que quería tener personas y esta atmósfera.
Cuando me vino la idea de cómo hacer esto,
tuve náuseas y mareos,
que es en realidad solo la adrenalina, probablemente,
pero para mí es una muy buena señal.
Y ahora quiero mostrarles en lo que he estado trabajando.
Es algo que no he mostrado antes, es como una vista previa, supongo,
de mi próxima exposición,
lo que tengo hasta ahora.
Amplios espacios
en lugar de la bañera aislada.
Voy fuera en lugar de permanecer en el interior.
Relajación del control,
saboreando las imperfecciones,
permitiendo que...
permitiendo imperfecciones.
Y en esa imperfección,
se puede encontrar una vulnerabilidad.
Podía sentir mi intención más profunda, lo que más me importa,
esa conexión humana
que puede suceder en un espacio donde no hay resistencia o control.
Quiero hacer pinturas de eso.
Así que esto es lo que he aprendido.
Todos vamos a tener grandes pérdidas en nuestras vidas,
tal vez un trabajo o una carrera,
relaciones, amor, nuestra juventud.
Vamos a perder nuestra salud,
personas a las que amamos.
Este tipo de pérdidas están fuera de nuestro control.
Son impredecibles,
y nos hacen arrodillarnos.
Y así, digo, déjenlas ser.
Arrodíllense. Sean humildes.
No traten de cambiarlo
o incluso de querer que sea diferente.
Simplemente es.
Y luego está el espacio,
y en ese espacio, sientan su vulnerabilidad,
qué es lo que más les importa,
la intención más profunda.
Y sean curiosos para conectar
con el qué y por el quién están realmente aquí,
despiertos y vivos.
Es lo que todos queremos.
Vamos a dar la oportunidad de encontrar algo hermoso
en lo desconocido, en lo impredecible
e incluso en lo horrible.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)